dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
Justine sort en boîte une boîte qui
s'appelle la charrette à
Brive-la-Gaillarde elle habite à une
quarantaine de kilomètres de là elle y
va en voiture mais elle est elle est en
bande avec ses amis
vingt ans donc une fois par mois il font
une fête ensemble elle boit probablement
un peu trop et un moment vers 3h 4h du
matin elle demande à sortir enfin elle
veut sortir prendre l'air éventuellement
même aller dormir dans sa voiture et il
a un de ses copains qui l'accompagnent
jusque là j'ai envie de vous dire tout
va bien
et alors qu'ils arrivent aux extérieurs
c'est-à-dire le copain est Justine un
individu celui qui est en garde à vue
actuellement va
décider de s'occuper de Justine en
disant aux copains rentre retourne à la
soirée je gère on se connaît
effectivement il se connaisse de vue
pour cette croisée plusieurs fois dans
boîte de nuit et à partir de là plus de
son puis d'image on a plus de nouvelles
de Justine alors le copain en question
celui qui qui l'a laissé aux abords de
la boîte
va prendre va retourner sur place va
retourner à la voiture de Justine
Justine a disparu le copain également
celui qui est en garde à vue a disparu
il s'appelle Lucas donc on l'appelait
Lucas sera plus simple Lucas a disparu
le copain appelle Lucas en disant mais
il a trouvé le numéro
quand ils se sont croisés sur le parking
il a pris les coordonnées de Lucas un
peu en grand frère en disant
scalping partir avec n'importe qui donc
il a les coordonnées de Lucas il
l'appelle et Lucas dit bah écoute elle a
les mieux elle est elle est partie
d'ailleurs je l'ai eu elle m'a envoyé un
message par la messagerie snapchat
elle est avec un WhatsApp snapchat
et donc et donc elle va et donc elle va
elle va bien elle est avec elle a
retrouvé un autre copain et et tout va
bien et là le le le celui à qui elle dit
qu'il dit ça s'inquiète un peu parce que
lui essaye de joindre Justine et elle ne
répond pas elle répondrait juste à
celui-là
le dimanche pas de nouvelles du coup
forcément les parents s'inquiètent
alertent les services de la gendarmerie
et très vite on pense cette affaire au
sérieux et le fameux Lucas va être
interpellé c'est un ouvrier agricole il
a 21 ans d'accord lorsque les gendarmes
arrivent chez lui pour l'interpeller il
trouve pas mieux que de prendre la fuite
à la vue des gendarmes d'accord ça fait
un élément supplémentaire on a rien à se
reprocher
on ne part pas en courant devant les
gendarmes donc il est antécédents ou pas
du tout pas à ma connaissance
très bien mais je ne sais pas c'est
et
il est donc placé en garde à vue on fait
une perquisition chez lui quand je dis
on ces gens-là
et là il trouve des traces de sang dans
la chambre de ce garçon de Lucas il
trouve également des traces de sang sur
le pommeau du levier de vitesse de la
voiture de Lucas et pire encore on
retrouve le sac à main de Justine aux
abords de la propriété c'est une ferme
aux abords de la propriété calciner par
la propriété évidemment c'est le sac
donc on retrouve le sac à main calciné
le sac à main de Justine donc
ça fait quand même beaucoup d'éléments
et il y a un dernier témoignage pour que
je pourrais être complet c'est une une
amie parce qu'en réalité Lucas on sait
pas très bien ce qu'il a fabriqué
accessoire là toujours est-il qu'il a
été un moment donné avec Justine ça
c'est acquis combien de temps on n'en
sait rien qu'est-ce qu'il a fait on n'en
sait rien pour l'instant en tout cas il
est revenu ensuite en boîte de nuit et
il est il a raccompagné une autre jeune
fille et le témoignage de cet autre
jeune fille est très intéressante parce
qu'elle dit qu'à un moment donné et un
téléphone qui a sonné dans la voiture et
que ce n'était pas celui de Lucas qu'il
avait deux téléphones sur lui alors on
ne sait pas ce qui est devenu le
téléphone de Justine et
lorsqu'il est en garde à vue et qu'il
est entendu sur ce point précis il dit
c'est un téléphone professionnel donc
j'ai deux téléphones perso et un
professionnel c'est
véritablement il a pas de téléphone
professionnel donc voilà on les a
vérifie assez vite
donc voilà en l'état où on est le
témoignage de la jeune fille qui l'a
accompagné après à part ça le il a
accompagné elle il y a eu il il a eu
aucun comportement alors effectivement
elle déclara qu'il était pas comme
d'habitude qu'il était complètement
renfermé qu'il était muet quasiment il
ne parlait pas
pas du tout son comportement habituel
les gens qui le connaissent
il avait déjà eu des comportements
bizarres avant elle c'est la première
fois qu'elle l'a trouvé bizarre quoi
c'est la première fois c'était quelqu'un
plutôt de d'en jouer de drôle enfin qui
aime faire la fête quand on est en boîte
de nuit c'est pour pour s'amuser et là
en l'occurrence dans la deuxième partie
de la nuit donc après des après la
disparition de Justine il est il change
de comportement il est il parle pas il
est il est il est muré alors
si vous nous rejoignez on part de on
parle de l'affaire Justine
cette jeune fille qui a disparu là
depuis combien de temps maintenant ça
fait dans la nuit samedi à dimanche
et on l'a toujours pas retrouvé voilà la
trace de Justine le procureur de la
République a donné une conférence de
presse à 17h30 sur cette affaire elle
est d'abord revenue sur les
perquisitions qui ont permis de donner
des éléments inquiétants regardez
des perquisitions ont été menées au sein
du domicile de l'intéressé ainsi que
dans son véhicule
des opérations de polices techniques et
scientifiques ont été effectués
lesquels ont permis de mettre en
évidence la présence de traces de sang
au sein du domicile de l'intéresser dans
sa chambre mais également dans son
véhicule au niveau du pommeau de levier
de vitesse
des analyses ADN sont actuellement en
cours afin d'établir le profil génétique
pouvant correspondre à ces traces de
sang
et un instant Michel ah oui dès le début
il y a une immense inquiétude parce que
Justine elle veut devenir aide-soignante
elle a un enfant elle a la garde de
l'enfant voilà la retrouver un petit ami
donc dès le début c'est vrai que la
famille a dit tout de suite c'est pas
normal elle n'aurait jamais fait ça et
donc voilà il y a eu une recherche pour
disparition inquiétante puis après pour
enlèvement et séquestration donc c'est
vrai que l'inquiétude est maximale et le
profil du suspect en garde à vue et
resserrer garde à vue prolongé de 24
heures le faisceau d'enquête vraiment
écoutez pour le moment lui il nie il
reste sur le côté j'ai laissé juste une
quelque part comme disait Michel et
quelqu'un l'a prise en charge et comment
il peut dire et comment il explique tous
les le sac qui a été retrouvé
comment il explique le fait qu'il se
soit ensuite quand les gendarmes sont
arrivés pour le moment il y a pas
d'éléments là-dessus pour le moment de
son côté c'est je je ne suis pas
responsable mais ça peut évoluer ils
espèrent que les 24 heures
supplémentaires vont le faire craquer
ils espèrent à mon avis surtout avoir
les retours d'ADN très rapidement et si
on arrive à établir que c'est le centre
Justine qui est retrouvé sur le pommeau
du levier de vitesse ainsi que dans la
chambre du suspect j'ai envie de vous
dire que il aura pas d'autres choix que
de s'expliquer ça peut ça mais ça met
combien de temps pour en urgence ça peut
aller très vite dans le délai de la
garde à vue d'accord alors la mère de
Justine explique que sa fille n'aurait
jamais disparu d'elle-même ce que vous
dites Gilles de cette façon sans donner
de nouvelles regardez samedi par mois
elle aime bien les retrouver quelques
copains elle danse et puis et puis elle
rentre elle rentre toujours parce que
parce que elle a un petit copain et
qu'il attend et parce que elle veut être
là parce que non Justine oui c'est ça
c'est sa petite soupape c'est un petit
par mois je suis très très famille je
vois ma fille tous les jours Justine
elle est pas comme ça c'est quelqu'un de
gentille c'est quelqu'un de serviable
elle est un peu naïve elle est jeune
elle voit peut-être pas le mal après
elle est pas elle est c'est pas
quelqu'un de bête elle est plutôt
intelligente mais elle est un peu naïve
c'est vrai
c'est très inquiétant alors visiblement
quand elle sort de la boîte elle ne va
pas bien c'est vrai elle se sent mal et
les enquêteurs pensent que cette
connaissance qu'elle avait ce jeune
homme aurait pu profiter de son état de
faiblesse ou du fait qu'elle aille mal
pour peut-être la raccompagner ou voilà
après on perd sa trace mais il y a un
côté inquiétant parce que Justine est
très structurée jamais le disparaissait
et effectivement comme dit la maman
jamais elle n'aurait pu faire ça sans
que quelqu'un sans que quelqu'un
n'agisse voilà alors il y a son papa
aussi qui s'est exprimé très ému
explique que l'attente est évidemment
insupportable à vivre et bien sûr c'est
vrai que c'est pour nous tous
[Musique]
le pire avec des éléments que nous a
donné le procureur de la République
regardez ce que dit ils sont pas morts
qui compte le plus pour nous là c'est de
pouvoir
te retrouver notre fille Justine pour la
resserrer dans nos bras
à quel moment terriblement voilà
et voilà c'est tout ce qu'on souhaite en
fait je pense que tout le monde est
gentil en fait avec elle et
le mal en fait et pas forcément il faut
passer il faut jamais s'inquiéter quand
on l'écoute il faut jamais s'inquiéter
mais voilà
jusqu'au jour où forcément s'inquiète
pour de bon en fait voilà pour l'instant
évidemment c'est dur parce que on a
toujours aucune nouvelle aucune trace
d'elle on voit que l'enquête avance mais
voilà c'est on est dans l'attente et
c'est insupportable
le sac à main de Justine retrouvée
calcinée c'est
c'est il était dans le
domicile au domicile de
sur les extérieurs de la du domicile de
du fameux Lucas d'accord oui la voiture
abandonnée aussi avec ses effets
personnels elle n'aurait pas laissé sa
voiture donc voilà il y a un faisceau
d'une intervention de quelqu'un
sur le parking c'est à dire qu'elle
avait laissé
personnels donc elle n'aurait pas fait
ça non plus voilà c'est pour ça que
c'est pour ça que dès le départ les
enquêteurs ont été extrêmement inquiets
comme nous tous alors la procureur a
parlé aussi de des moyens mis en place
qui ont permis de découvrir de nouveaux
éléments regardez
le sac à main de Justine verac contenant
pardon des effets personnels a été
découvert calcinée à proximité du
domicile de du gardien à vue à
l'extérieur de ce dernier
la garde à vue du mise en cause a été
prolongée pour une nouvelle période de
24 heures et les auditions de nombreux
témoins se poursuivent encore
on a des raisons d'être inquiets Michel
Marie
on a toujours des raisons d'être inquiet
quand une jeune fille de 20 ans
disparaît dans ces conditions-là dans
ces circonstances là quand il y a
on retrouve des traces de sang dans au
domicile d'un suspect qui est avec elle
et qui est le dernier à l'avoir vu
vivante
des traces de sang également sur le
pommeau de vitesse
voilà il y a eu alors on est en pleine
campagne il y a eu des recherches très
importantes qui ont été faites pour
essayer de retrouver trace d'elle
vivante de préférence évidemment
hélicoptère drone
plongeur parce qu'il y a pas mal de
détente dans le dans le secteur à
proximité du domicile de Lucas pour
l'instant même les chiens l'équipe
cynophile a été mise en action alors
justement c'est ça qu'on va parler
également les autorités ont déployé
un moyen incroyable pour tenter de
retrouver Justine une battue dans les
bois des plongeurs dans un étang une
équipe cynophile il y a des militaires
aussi qui viennent ainsi on appuie au
des forces de l'ordre qui mènent
l'enquête voilà pour pour aider ces
moyens incroyables et renfort de
l'Apologie judiciaire de Limoges donc là
actuellement c'est
on cherche partout
ils ont mis absolument tout ce qui
pouvait mettre en terme d'effectif en
terme de matériel en termes ils ont ils
prennent la faire très très aussi grand
moyen d'innombrables témoins entendu
tous les gens qui étaient dans la
discothèque tout l'entourage donc ils
ont agi très vite parce qu'ils ont pris
ça très au sérieux tout de suite mais
elle ne peut pas être séquestrée par le
suspect numéro un puisqu'il est en garde
à vue donc il y a la plus grande
inquiétude pour l'instant de la retrouve
pas mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
possible vous vous dites Michel j'ai
elle peut être enfermée quelque part
avant que le suspense se fasse arrêter
si tenté soit lui bon aujourd'hui ils
ont ils ont fait ils ont fouillé toute
la maison du suspect
le sac à main à l'extérieur des traces
de sang dans la chambre et dans sa
voiture
il y a ces affaires mais elle y a rien
il y a rien il y a ce téléphone
effectivement qui pourrait être le sien
mais voilà il y a rien d'autre donc cet
homme sur une connaissance amicale
rencontrer quelquefois au sein de la
boîte de nuit c'est quelqu'un qui a le
colis c'est comme ça c'est pas un miel
donc voilà c'était voilà quelqu'un
qu'elle croisait quelquefois dans cette
boîte de nuit donc il a proposé de la
raccompagner en voiture et de l'aider
alors qu'elle ne se sentait pas bien et
depuis plus de nouvelles de Justine
regardez Justine voilà si on sait jamais
voilà si vous l'avez vu si vous avez
une jeune fille qui ressemble à Justine
on a voilà on s'est jamais tous les
éléments seront importants dans ce genre
de qui est un Michel
Gilles donc là tout le monde va être
entendu tout le monde est entendu il y a
plein de témoins mais visiblement voyez
la famille aussi demande à ce que ce
soit rendu public parce que chaque
indice bien sûr la famille a envie d'y
croire a envie de nous aussi évidemment
tout le monde Michel Marie dans les dans
les affaires comme celle-ci
au bout voilà là ça fait plusieurs jours
ça fait maintenant ça va faire trois
jours trois jours est-ce qu'il y a eu
des cas on a retrouvé voilà la jeune
fille après
je veux pas perdre espoir
de toute façon tant qu'on ne l'a pas
retrouvé on va la considérer comme
vivante
on recherche une expertise on est
inquiet forcément on a on a peu d'espoir
mais on a tous envie qu'elle étudiante
on sait jamais peut-être qu'il y a du
sang dans la nature et sur le pommeau de
qu'elle est morte elle peut ils peuvent
s'être battus mais elle peut être
blessée elle peut avoir donc là il faut
la retrouver
quand même c'est assez troublant
pourquoi il aurait voulu une bagarre
lui il veut pas il veut se débarrasser
du sac il le fait il le brûle c'est
c'est vrai qu'il y a quand même de
fortes
raisons de s'inquiéter il y a de bonnes
raisons de s'inquiéter mais pour
l'instant on recherche une Justine
vivante c'est ce qu'on recherche et si
vous avez voilà aperçu Justine si vous
avez des éléments donnez les vraiment au
plus vite chaque minute content